I was raped and abused by someone who I
really trusted I actually attempted to
take my own life because of it Ellie is
a Survivor attacked by her boyfriend
abused at University when she was 20.
the jury did get to hear my rapist
confess on tape and obviously I did
manage to secure a guilty farad out but
I think it's interesting to note that
that verdict wasn't actually unanimous
and so the amount of evidence that it
takes to secure conviction is enormous
and even then not everyone that on that
jury is going to believe you
under major new plans duties would be
replaced with a single judge as part of
a pilot in high court rape cases for all
other trials Judy sizes would reduce 15
people cut to 12 and eight of them would
be required to return a guilty verdict
to convict and Scotland's unique not
proven verdict would be scrapped it
essentially means the same as not guilty
but is seen as confusing and creates a
stigma for not completely clearing the
accused
duties bring their attitudes and
prejudices and force assumptions to be
here for making decisions in rape cases
that has contributing to guilty men
walking free these are the biggest
proposed changes to Scotland's legal
system in Generations they're not proven
verdict delivered by juries in
courtrooms like this one date back
hundreds of years Hamza yusuf's
Administration here in Scotland want to
improve Dreadful conviction rates only
around half of rape cases end up in a
guilty verdict compare that to on
average 90 percent in other cases but it
is feared that these changes could lead
to more innocent people being sent to
prison the idea that stay appointed
judges are going to replace civilians in
trying other civilians it's a
frightening concept I mean it's the
first thing that an authoritarian
government does an argument denied by
ministers I won't be appealing to the
lowest common denominator in this debate
because we owe victims of crying so much
better
those changes are likely years away
controversy over the courts is only just
beginning Conor Gillis Sky News
Edinburgh